de la terre on veut mais moi il
émerveille il me semble que la misère
serait moins pénible au soleil
[Musique]
c'est la mine sombre
essentiel pour le faire merci
les petits copains à terre j'aime pas
les pizzas je déteste ça et sa sauce
piquante scène pas ça non plus rater
partir de matériaux merci la bulle
ventes au 1 4 kg
[Musique]
j'aime pas les plans téléphone josette
transformé en grenouille je suis un cas
d'avoir il pousse renouil a battu les
déjà s'il faut pas rester sur le plateau
comme sa poêlée semble qu'avant il faut
aller à khartoum fallait faire des
courses me dégoûte images garde faisant
la rue comme ça c'est un gâchis sont
[Musique]
prévues
regardez désert vianney pour
[Musique]
partout où nous le souhaitons
m
[Musique]
et
m
talabani
non non ne l'écouté pas tata nano my
book world is our new es-tu free seul
jeune sorcière le plus notre ami se
donner au peuple aux omissions embrasse
addison de la terre et moi il me semble
que la misère
[Musique]